so a fourth fight I think is tough
fourth fight stuff not to mention Ilia
topiria is going to get the next uh shot
at the champ there when volkanovsky so
that's not even announced yet so he's
gonna have to wait for that he said he
doesn't mind beating up the contenders
either the best case there for Max
there's two what I think there's two
options if I'm his management we're
looking at this you're going all right
vokanovski and Ilya tuberia is next
we need to appear to win if topir wins
then you'd fight Ilya that's a fight I'd
love that fight yeah that's an amazing
fight Chancellor topir winning not good
the UFC probably didn't do a fourth
fight for you so do we take six to eight
months put on a little bit of weight and
uh go end up and remember Max always
older now too do we go up to 55.